this is a special episode guys oh yeah
it is we're we're doing the first
podcast episode out of a freaking bank
vault okay
this is literally a bank vault how crazy
is that you've been talking about this
dreaming this for how long pat
well you know first of all the whole
book i the academy right the fiction
book academy it the it's based on a
vault and the painting dead mentors if
you want to david if you can pull up
that
painting
that i had at the office then i got at
the house just type in dead mentors
yeah type in dead mentors oh tyler's
doing that not david okay got it go to
images right there if you look at that
painting that is a vault okay you see
the vault around it inside the vault as
bookshelves
and
shaw lincoln kennedy einstein milton
friedman mlk senna tupac myself we're
having a conversation together with a
lot of different things and two books
are sitting on that table
one is uh uh iron atlas shrut uh uh
atlas shrugged and the other one is your
favorite book communist manifesto that's
sitting there so that's gerard's
favorite book to begin gerard's
different about me than every other
socialist in america is i've actually
read the comments
sir
how many socialists do you think i've
actually read that i'm guessing very few
and they they're so illiterate it's hard
for me to tell oh it's just just poking
so here we are in the bar right you got
the painting of the dead manners four
guys who got shot four guys that didn't
and uh we're all here
so the good news is everybody here is a
lifetime we're gonna be okay so there's
that but the uh dude if they had done a
little bit of research on you they could
have pumped the price of this place up
probably 2x3x if they had just known a
little well you know the story about how
we bought this building
do you know the story let's hear the
story okay so here's the story actually
it was a coincidence in an accident
i was here with you and then there was
another building
so we we came and i made an offer on
this building and the offer i made the
the owner of the building he only his
counteroffer he came down like you know
twenty five fifty thousand dollars i'm
like what is this all about so my
realtor calls his path don't get upset
it's it's we can still counter i said
i'm out i'm done i'm not making the
counter offer and he says no no let's
make a counteroffer something could
happen i said i am out i'm not making
the counter offer anyways long story
short
i buy the other building off of federal
we buy the building you've been to the
federal building there as well it's a
lot of build that we bring all the
people to help us build the place out
and i hired this designer to show up and
he shows up the best in town designer
everybody in the market knows who he is
a beast of a designer he shows up good
looking guy well spoken you know he
knows what he's doing
i said so what are you based out of he
says my office headquarters based out of
fort lauderdale so no way yeah it's very
cool i said
we're in fort lauderdale this is alpha
dixie
i said we're in dixie he gives the
address i said
let me get this straight i made an offer
on your building
he says you did make an offer on the
building i said why did you only come
down as much as you did he said well i
saw who you were i'm like i don't know i
don't negotiate against this guy i said
i better come down laura i said listen
you still want to do something or not i
text him that night i said
uh is it a waste of my time if i make an
offer on the building he said it's not a
waste your time i made an offer uh cash
offer
and we went back and forth within three
or four days we
figured it out we finalized it nicest
guy in the world by the way absolute
stud of a guy he is and then we bought
this building and the idea was to buy
one building accidentally we bought two
buildings so
the other building really the other way
every time that happened the other
building we bought simply for gerrard to
go hang out with his friends that's what
gerard's gonna be doing ready to ride
he's gonna have an underground thing
going on very soon stay tuned for it
it's known as the lumber yard
by the way guys worked all night to
build this up so shout out to him
jorge
who set up his stuff right next door to
eric to david to everybody that worked
on that
jorge and robert like dude jorge is like
that dude is like construction ketchup
there is nothing he doesn't go well with
i mean he does audio he does it in
english he does it in spanish he's got
beautiful long hair that dude's a beast
he is a beast you're man crush
what time did we get back here last
night after the business planning oh we
so we had the business planning workshop
yesterday which ended i don't know what
time it is it's a 9 30 with this year
yeah we come here at 9 30 we see this
place
uh i had to get covered tested because i
got a flight right afterwards too vegas
with tom
and then we come today
and we do this stuff but we come here
last night this place was empty i was
like we're not having a podcast nothing
yeah there's no i don't know if it's
gonna get done actually i actually was
giving robert a little bit of [ __ ] i was
like we got a plan i left here at nine i
was like we got a plan b right like we
have a plan b if this isn't ready we
grab another pocket he's like yeah yeah
we got we're gonna go back to the old
office
there bro with what equipment yeah we're
gonna do picnic tables in the parking
lot it's gonna be very florida so put a
button on this pat how does it feel this
was your dream this is your vision it
started with the vault the picture the
everything now here we are yeah the
headquarters were in the vault it's all
come
i have one rule man i i i have one rule
anything i do when i'm making money we
have to have fun making money okay if
we're running a business whether it's
insurance whether it's this whether it's
media whatever we're doing fun has to be
at the you know foundation of it you got
to have fun with the people that you're
working with and how much more fun
you're going to have than doing a
freaking podcast in a bank vault who the
hell puts a podcast on a bank vault but
we got a podcast on a bank vault now so
every time we invite guests
you know the podcast isn't a bank vault
right what do you mean it's a bank vault
this was a bank okay this was the vault
of chase bank
and now it is a podcast it's pretty
crazy to do that there's only one thing
missing and i want to task the
valuetainers listening right now we we
need the pbd podcast logo board that we
have coming up so maybe they can if
you're out there in the in the pbd
podcast world if you have an idea for
the pbd podcast logo a new pvd podcast
logo for the vault submit it yeah maybe
yours will be the one that gets chosen
that's that's a good idea and then the
other part is this shelf if you if you
focus on the shelves david this shelf is
built for the best gifts that are sent
unique gifts that are send that fit here
don't send us a big thing because we
can't fit it there the best ones are
going to make it on this shelf if
anybody wants to send anything out here
to us
we got some room to put stuff on the
shelves so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you